[Music]
good afternoon dr. vest professor of
mrs. gray distinguished guests who
include today mrs. McVicker and
Margaret's two sisters and in Victoria
it's my pleasure to be able to welcome
you all today
to the McVicker lecture and subsequent
discussions about teaching today we
celebrate great teachers great teaching
and a woman who is passionate about both
will hear more about Margaret MacVicar
later from our speaker as well as from a
wonderful video that Bob Randolph will
show later on in the program let me say
here however that Margaret was really
one of a kind
in the 30 years that I've been
affiliated with MIT I don't think I have
met anyone who had a shorter mean
waiting time between interesting ideas
about how to improve the quality of
undergraduate education than Margaret
MacVicar Margaret understood that
teaching and learning were not the same
thing she appreciated the role that
research plays in teaching of
undergraduates and indeed Europe is one
of her greatest legacies not only to MIT
but to undergraduate education
throughout the United States in the
world she recognized that teaching and
learning are not segregated between
teacher and student and that students
learn from teachers and teachers learn
from students as well she was truly a
remarkable person in MIT is a far better
place because of her as research
universities go MIT is a little bit
different than most of our competition
while the u.s. is blessed with many
great
search institutions the educational
experience at MIT is a bit different
than one encounters at places like
Harvard and Princeton and in Stanford in
thinking about who to invite today to
give the McVicker lecture it was
important to us that we find somebody
who really understood and appreciated
what it was to be an MIT student we also
wanted somebody who was a terrific
teacher and educator in their own right
and we also wanted somebody who knew and
appreciated and could convey the essence
and spirit of Margaret and once we had
articulated those criteria there was
really only one person who left to mind
and that was ET Goldman Goldenberg
professor of political science and
public policy at the University of
Michigan now Edie attended MIT as an
undergraduate majored in political
science and she and Margaret were
roommates and lifelong friends and
indeed Edie and I were talking on the
way over here
Edie had the pleasure as did Margaret of
being the first group of women to occupy
McCormick Hall that meant also that Edie
and Margaret had the privilege of being
the first residents of McCormick Hall to
violate the policy on having pets in the
dorm an issue which lives to this day I
should
I should tell you after graduating from
MIT in 1967 Eadie went West in search of
warmer weather and found herself at
Stanford where she received her PhD in
political science and then returned to
the colder climes of the north where she
joined the political science faculty at
the University of Michigan she's held
numerous positions of leadership at U of
M including being the director of the
Institute of Public Policy Studies as
well as the Dean of the College of
literature science 'as in the arts now
again just to give you a sense of the
scale of that operation to repeat a
comment that the Chuck made earlier the
College of literature science and the
arts known by us Michiganders as LS an a
has a larger student body than MIT does
it has a larger faculty than mi deed
does and it has a larger instructional
budget that MIT does so being Dean of of
LS na is indeed an extraordinarily
challenging position in IDI managed that
job with a typical aplomb for the ten
years that she held that position now
what's not widely known about Edie is
that she is also directly responsible
personally I believe for Chuck vest
being our president know it's not
something that everybody knows around
here but it's true because if you read
Edie's bio carefully and check the dates
you will see that in 1988 Edie served on
a search committee that found a new
Provost for the University of Michigan
located him amongst the ranks of
Engineers you could tell that she held
engineers in high esteem and it was from
that position that chuck joins us so
thank you for thank you for your good
work since stepping down as dean Edie
has returned to the ranks of the
professora
it's nice to know that there is life
after deanship she is a distinguished
educator a distinguished scholar Edie
has
written widely and extensively about
civil service she's also written about
the role of media in American political
campaigns
she's an extraordinarily good friend of
MIT and continues to serve this fine
institution as a member of the MIT
corporation and a chairman and chairman
of the visiting committee for the
Department of Political Science I can
think of no better person to give the
first McVicker lecture of the millennium
which follows on the heels of the 30th
anniversary of Europe then professor
Eadie Goldenberg Eadie welcome
[Applause]
well thanks Larry and thanks all of you
it's a it's a real honor for me to be
here to add my congratulations to the
new McVicker fellows we were just
together for lunch and what an
impressive group that is to honor my
undergraduate alma mater and of course
to remember my late friend and college
roommate mark of McVicker and it's
especially exciting to be here on the
occasion of the 30th anniversary of
Europe a program that Margaret launched
that has had enormous impact here at MIT
and around the country but more on that
later when I think about Margaret and I
think about lecturing in 6 120 I can't
help but remember a call I had from her
one day she lectured in this room and
Margaret wasn't very tall as you can see
from her family and she needed to use
all of the blackboard so she had a
student bring in a bench and she would
write on the blackboard standing on the
bench and then the student would come
and move the bench and she'd write on
the blackboard standing on the bench and
one day she got so interested in writing
on the blackboard that she fell off the
end of the bench she was of course very
embarrassed but I've got to say that
that was a memorable lecture for her and
for her students and I'm sure that all
of us could come up with one story like
that some embarrassment that we suffered
while we were teaching I want to say a
word about the title of the talk posters
have to be printed and so the Provost
asked for a title some time ago and it
was late at night and I was feeling a
little silly kind of used the the the
way I used to feel when I was up all
night studying for a physics exam and
remember one night Margaret and I were
writing the slightly body verses about
BCS theory or some something like that I
suggested this title as a joke but the
more I thought about it the more I liked
it for one thing the letters for rat are
embedded and slightly interrupted order
granted in undergraduate for another
Margaret and I were both Dean's at the
same time we were both deeply involved
in undergraduate education and as you
all know a Dean is a mouse and training
to be a rat for a third when a lot of
people think about rats they think about
lab rats a widely recognized symbol of
science and research and one that's
fitting for talking at my tea but when I
think about rat and MIT I think about
the brass rat
nature's engineer a real symbol of MIT
more on the rat later so I was asked to
say something visionary about the place
of undergraduate education in the
research university to do this in the
special context of MIT to remember
market and please to wrap it all up
without going on too long that's a tall
order as I reflected on my assignment I
decided to let Margaret be the visionary
to use four of Margaret's visionary
ideas to organize my comments today
these four ideas are these first
undergraduate education is a core
responsibility of MIT and of all
research universities second
undergraduate education means breadth
and depth third research experiences
powerfully enhance the undergraduate
experience and fourth every individual
student matters so let's take up each of
these in turn
in 1986 Margaret Megan remarks
at an MIT corporation meeting in which
she said that MIT must have at its heart
commitment to a world-class
undergraduate educational program one of
her favorite sayings from antiquity was
to prepare for one year.you plant rice
to prepare for 10 you set trees to
prepare for 100 years you educate people
margaret was an MIT undergraduate and
also an MIT doctoral student she spent
three years at each and therefore never
knew what class she was in by the way
and while she believed in the
fundamental importance of research and
graduate education at MIT she never
wavered from the view that undergraduate
education is the fundamental purpose of
MIT that undergraduates should be at the
center of the Institute's complex
mission and in this as in so many other
things Margaret was a good decade ahead
of her peers sometime around 1990 the
rest of us woke up other research
universities caught on to the reality
that if undergraduates continued to be
neglected relative to other aspects of
their mission then universities would
suffer and suffer badly at the hands of
intrusive legislators unhappy alums
donors value conscious parents and
students in 1989 I began my years as
Dean of Arts and Sciences at Michigan
with an agenda that included Rees
entering undergraduate education and our
institutional mission four years after
that in 1993 Donald Kennedy was
pondering and writing is it possible to
engage a research oriented faculty such
as that at Stanford more deeply with our
students now the criticisms that
galvanized the rest of us weren't
exactly new back in 1828 the trustees
and faculty at Yale concluded that not
one of our colleges is a place of
thorough learning
and not one of the better class of them
does half of what it might do by
bringing the minds of its instructors to
act directly on the minds of its pupils
and in 1893 the president of Vassar
commented this way on the Vassar faculty
one is obliged to suspect at times that
the student comes to be regarded by the
faculty as a mere disturber of ideal
schemes and as a disquieting element in
what without students might be a fairly
pleasant life what is new about the
criticisms of the 80s and 90s is that
they come came and still come from
outside of academia and they were and
our frequent pointed and relentless what
is also new for our universities today
is that our educational challenges are
greater than they were in the 19th
century we admit a more diverse student
body we pursue a more varied and
complicated institutional mission our
students face a present and a future of
rapid change and demographic diversity
in a society that stresses knowledge and
information the complex societal
problems we face have led to more and
more specialization understanding basic
social questions requires more knowledge
than any one person has our students
need broader and more interdisciplinary
understandings of the world they also
need to develop the ability to cooperate
with others who bring complementary
specialized information to address
problems as a whole which leads me to
the second point a good education
requires both depth and breadth in 1985
margaret shared her ideas with paul gray
then president as he prepared a speech
to welcome new students to MIT Margaret
wrote quote uncommon excellence in a
scientific or engineering field is not
enough it must be accompanied by an
understanding of the social and human
content
by an ability to comprehend your work in
its broadest humanistic terms a year
later Margaret herself welcomed the 86
entering class with thoughts about the
reforms to be proposed for general
Institute requirements in particular the
Haas or humanity and humanities and
social science requirements and she said
you are likely aware of the major
movement in the liberal arts colleges to
reformulate their core curriculum to
include strong science to include
mathematics and to include exposure to
technology to complement the humanities
Arts and Social Sciences core MIT has
long such had a program of this sort of
equal weighting of humanities Arts and
Social Sciences with the sciences and
mathematics now having been in under an
MIT undergraduate myself if Margaret
were here today I would certainly
quibble with the idea of equal weighting
or at least that that's what was
happening in the 60s when I was a
student here but the general idea of
balance and breadth is valid and goes
back a long way I was interested to read
a copy of the forth Arthur D little
memorial lecture at MIT in 1949 by
Detlef W Bronk then president of Johns
Hopkins and by the way a PhD in physics
from Michigan his lecture was entitled
the unity of sciences and the humanities
president Bronk described MIT then as a
place where the course of Technology is
guided by considerations of human
motives and human values and he argued
in that lecture that historical
perspective is essential to creative
imagination in all of all sorts
including creative imagination in
science and engineering and yet we've
seen a shift in student interests around
the country away from the humanities and
toward pre professional training at the
undergraduate level I think it's
captured quite well in a cartoon some of
you may have seen in the Chronicle for
higher education a couple of weeks ago a
student is talking with a friend of his
and he says my dad says I
waste my time with that general
education stuff but hey it's my life and
I want to broaden myself so I'm taking
business accounting International
Accounting ecological accounting and
accounting and literature in my view
this trend toward the pre-professional
and away from the humanities is
unhealthy and an unwelcome development
that undermines needed balance in
undergraduate education a liberal arts
education depends on grounding in the
humanities as well as in science and
social science it has staying power
beyond the short life of technical
training a good education and the
liberal arts introduces students to
fundamental issues as they have been
explored by others through the ages
including exposure to ideas feelings
problems and situations that are common
to the human experience and to the ways
that respected minds and revered hearts
have dealt with them my goals for
undergraduate education are these to
provide students with a solid foundation
for problem-solving to help students
understand others from different
backgrounds and to interact effectively
with them to help students examine their
own assumptions and avoid being taken in
by specious arguments to help students
feel connected with others who have
dealt with similar feelings or
situations or problems in the past to
open students eyes and minds to other
cultures thereby coming to understand
their own better to provide a deeper
sense of self and citizenship to develop
valued employees responsible citizens
and effective leaders in some to teach
students how to learn and to inspire a
zest for learning that will last a
lifetime
now these sound to me very like the
goals of an MIT education or at least
what I think of as the goals of an MIT
education helping students develop a
balance between openness to new ideas
and a healthy skepticism of those same
ideas a bell
that permits knowledge to advance this
requires breath as well as depth
research experiences enhanced
undergraduate education the 1957 Arthur
D little lecture was copies are sitting
out there that was of course the famous
generation of greatness by Edwin H land
he called in that lecture for faculty
Usher's who would introduce students to
the research environment others tried to
make lands idea a reality at MIT but
failed then some 30 years ago Paul Gray
turned to market McVicar and Margaret
built on lands idea molding it
brilliantly to mi t--'s culture that was
the beginning of Europe to succeed at
MIT Europe had to be non-bureaucratic on
the one hand and yet academically
credible on the other and it's been both
Margaret made it work she stayed with it
and personally made those many critical
individual decisions to support or not
to support to give credit or not to give
credit to place students off campus or
not to play students off campus the
decisions these individual decisions
that gave Europe its culture its
reputation its solid grounding Europe
has transformed the undergraduate
experience at MIT and at colleges and
universities all around the country in
1973 MIT students presented the Erwin
sizer award for the most significant
contribution to education at MIT to
Margaret and to Europe in 1986 Margaret
was honored with a national award the
Charles a Dana Foundation commendation
and higher education for her design and
implementation of Europe at MIT now
University Teaching may be the only
profession where practitioners feel
qualified to practice without any formal
training and without reading any of the
literature that relates to what they do
evidence on student learning dates back
to the 19th century but it has not been
well understood are well regarded by
faculty outside of the schools of
Education which aren't held in all that
high repute and outside of departments
of cognitive and developmental
psychology some of this literature
doesn't deserve a lot of attention
because it isn't especially convincing
but it is compelling to me on three
points first students learn more when
they are engaged and involved second
students learn more when they cooperate
with others on problem solving and third
the quality of teaching affects what
students learn Europe engages students
with real problems in cooperative
settings with teacher collaborators who
are deeply engaged in the problems
themselves this is a prize-winning
recipe for successful learning one of
Margaret's favorite sayings she
attributed to Confucius I hear and I
forget I see and I remember I do and I
understand your op students do UROP has
been emulated all over the country many
argue that MIT is unique that a program
like Europe can work in MIT but not
elsewhere because of the special talents
of MIT undergraduates and because of the
special place that this is I heard this
very argument two weeks ago in New York
at a meeting of the Carnegie Corporation
it's a meeting devoted to a discussion
of undergraduate education and it's true
that many of the early efforts to clone
Europe and other institutions failed but
today there are hundreds of
undergraduate research programs at
institutions all around the country they
even have their own National
Organization of undergraduate research
that's when you know that something has
really become a tour it really got its
start right here I inherited a fledgling
Europe program at Michigan
in 1989 that at that time enrolled 14
students in an undergraduate student
body of 24,000 over the next period of
my deanship we built Europe to a
thousand first and second year students
and probably twice as many juniors and
seniors and it's still growing there are
three distinctive features of Europe at
Michigan worth mentioning first from the
beginning our program has focused on
students at-risk underrepresented
minority students who we know drop out
at higher rates the majority students
regardless of their preparation coming
in and women in science and engineering
who we know often don't complete the
majors that they set out to do we
decided to concentrate not on our honor
students but rather on students who were
more challenged academically second we
needed to reach these students early so
our program has focused on Europe
experiences in the first and second
years maybe the juniors and seniors
already had research experiences through
their majors or through honors but there
were virtually none for first and second
year students third and this is unusual
for a higher education setting we
decided to evaluate our program
seriously and designed it with that in
mind including random assignment of
students to participate or not to
participate in Europe our research
results show that undergraduate research
works it improves the learning
experience for all students but
especially for underrepresented minority
students including those who aren't
performing well in class and for women
in science and engineering the greatest
payoff comes in the second term of a
full year experience it takes the
students that long to figure out what it
is that they're doing and there's some
kind of aha that happens around the
Christmas holiday break when they start
getting it or sometimes it's in January
so our Europe is always a year along
because we want them to have that
experience now someone
let me have it earlier but we want to be
sure they have that experience
undergraduate research promotes greater
involvement by students with the
academic life of the University a
positive side benefit is that working
with students in research reminds our
faculty of the joys of discovery as seen
through the eyes of novices I've heard
from more than one faculty member
especially in professional schools as I
say I haven't been I haven't taught an
undergraduate ever because we don't have
any and this is just wonderful this is
just such an eye-opener over 90% of the
faculty at Michigan who volunteer to
work with Europe students volunteer a
second time about 40% of our first and
second-year Europe placements are in the
medical school Europe is one of the few
effective ways we found for
undergraduates at Michigan to work with
medical school faculty in ways that are
valued by the medical school faculty and
it's not just at Michigan a 1995
publication reports that Europe
experiences at the University of
Washington and at Radcliffe college
enhanced women's aspirations in science
and engineering preliminary findings of
yet another studies suggest that the
most powerful I'm quoting the most
powerful undergraduate undergraduate
learning environments may occur in
research universities that also attend
to the undergraduate program so as
research universities around the country
have struggled to recenter undergraduate
education in their missions their
leaders have struggled to articulate
what it is that their institutions have
to offer to undergraduates in fact
research universities have a lot to
offer to undergraduates they enjoy a
comparative advantage in providing a
wide variety of research experiences
with faculty who learn for a living
faculty who are the leading scholars
across a wide range of opportunities in
arts and sciences and in the
professional schools and undergraduate
research is an approach that treats each
student as an individual learner which
brings me to the fourth point each
individual student matters nobody I know
believe that more than Margaret love and
appreciation poured in from her students
in notes and cards to Margaret when she
became ill Margaret took a personal
interest in every student who came her
way the brilliant ones as well as the
merely talented ones she loved
commencements she used she actually lost
her voice on numerous occasions you'll
remember because she spent so much time
practicing in order to pronounce every
single name correctly she felt at that
moment when the students walked across
that stage was a moment that deserved
special care and recognition when one of
Margaret's students father died he had
to leave MIT and return the Michigan
Margaret arranged for mentors for him at
work and at school when I was preparing
a charge to our own Committee on the
undergraduate experience at Michigan
Margaret helped me with the language
that says in part every student is an
irreplaceable asset of talent promise
and aspiration I could never have said
it better
Margaret taught important lessons about
the value of every individual student
perhaps especially important lessons for
those of us at large public institutions
our student faculty ratio is an even
greater challenge than yours and
sometimes we feel overwhelmed by sheer
numbers of students one benefit of
Europe placements with faculty and
professional schools and with research
scientists is that it the pool of
mentors for undergraduates is vastly
expanded beyond the size of the Arts and
Sciences faculty alone
this makes individual attention to
undergraduates in places like Michigan
possible
Margaret's legacy is very much with us
she would be pleased with our progress
today undergraduate education is
recognized as a core responsibility at
MIT and at most research universities
around the country a high quality
undergraduate experience requires Deb
than one or two areas in breadth across
many liberal arts colleges are worrying
and fussing about how to strengthen
their sciences and math MIT of course
has an outstanding science and math and
engineering capability but today there
is also much more both some much
stronger humanities and arts environment
than when I was here as a student
research experiences whether in class or
in the lab are much more available for
undergraduates even in their first and
second years and even for students who
aren't academic stars and every
individual student matters so where's
the rat in undergraduate education well
not just embedded in the phrase it's in
the belief that excellence in research
and teaching go together
and unwillingness to accept the view
that one can be excellent only in
research or teaching but not in both
I've been struck at Michigan that the
departments and programs that have Vogt
devoted real energy and imagination to
their undergraduate programs are either
already rated in the top 10 in terms of
research excellence or they're making
they're making moves in that direction
research and teaching are 80 can and do
go together the rat is also of course
the brass rat where's MIT in
undergraduate education well in a
leadership position as it should be
there's a strong tradition of national
impact by MIT and undergraduate
education in physics and in some areas
of engineering what is special over the
last 30 years is mi t--'s leadership and
undergraduate research which has
transformed colleges and universities
affecting areas of inquiry in science
and engineering of course but also in
social science the arts and the
humanities undergraduate research works
and the full set of possibilities for
advances in undergraduate research are
not yet realized we're clearly on the
right track now Will Rogers once said
that even if you are on the right track
you'll get run over if you just sit
there
Margaret would never have wanted us to
rest on our laurels and become
complacent with our achievements she
would insist on a constant stir in
undergraduate education in using our
imagination to continue to improve the
learning environment for our students I
don't know what the next nationally
notable educational innovation will be
to emerge from MIT maybe it'll grow out
of the partnership with Microsoft and
other corporations or maybe from the
partnership with Cambridge University
and other universities around the world
are given the role that MIT is on of
late maybe it'll be an interplanetary
partnership
I imagine m-squared IT a collaboration
with some University on Mars but more
likely it'll emerge from the imagination
in a single lab or classroom John
Gardner wrote that an institution's true
supporter is a loving critic who must
never be indifferent Margaret was always
a loving critic of MIT I'm delighted
that Margaret's name is associated with
the McVicker fellows since they so
appropriately capture her devotion to
students and to the educational
experience of undergraduates and as an
alum and another loving critic of MIT
I'm delighted that the McVicker Awards
publicly acknowledged in the outstanding
contributions individual faculty make to
the MIT experience this has been a
special honor for me today I'm glad
we're all here together to remember
Margaret and her signal contributions
and to celebrate faculty students in a
very special place MIT
[Applause]
institutions are 90% people in 10% image
the people create and sustain the image
and then they move on this is another
way of saying that we stand on the
shoulders of those who have gone before
us we all nurture the image that is MIT
now we know that to be true but
sometimes we fall off the track in one
of two ways we may worship those who've
gone before or we may forget those who
have preceded us it seems to me that
these last two days we have avoided both
extremes while remembering Margaret
MacVicar shortly after the announcement
of last year's McVicker fellows
president vest wisely asked if there was
some way those who were new fellows
could be introduced to Margaret her
spirit and her values he had been
prodded I suspect by others but this
film that you're about to see is the
result of his request his interest and
let it be said his budget
we are in his debt as well as we are in
the debt to the talents of Jay Collier
and Larry Gallagher and I think debt is
the right word and not too strong a word
for this film while brief really does
approach the profound Margaret MacVicar
you see personifies what is best about
this place and in remembering her we're
reminded of the values that are at the
heart of MIT and these values are each
year personified too fresh in the new
McVicker fellows may the film not only
remind us of a strong and influential
colleague but call us all to reaffirm
what we each do to make MIT the flagship
institution that it is enjoy the film
she was an educator a catalyst an
innovator she had the ability to step up
to almost any challenge or opportunity
she was a person who could hold 30
different projects together and still
have time to go up to her farm in Maine
for the weekend she was not a person who
was easily discouraged she fought for
her students she held us to high
standards and she had a certain inner
strength and inner confidence she was
also a wonderful human being a great
colleague and a great friend well let's
start with Margaret's undergraduate
years here she came in the middle 60s at
a time when MIT was endeavoring to admit
more young women Margaret and I met as
roommates and McCormick Hall and in my
team
she served while she was a student as
president of the Association of Women
students and we explored all of the
states of New England together we drove
all over the place but the place that
really caught her attention was named
after her undergraduate education here
she pursued a doctorate and she spent
some time in England and she returned
here in the late 1960s with an
appointment as an instructor in physics
and so beginning in the summer of 1969
she began preparing the way for the
undergraduate research opportunities
program as it came to be called I
started in Margaret's laboratory as a
UROP student and when I left her
laboratory had my PhD as I recall that
first fall there were just 20 or 30
students who participated there was a
UROP office she was it she prided
herself on putting that program forward
with relatively little money
Margaret really valued the people in the
laboratory and that was how she focused
her energies it was going that the
advances were going to be made by the
people not by the equipment the only
condition associated with involving a
student in Europe is that a faculty
member had to say this work if performed
is worthy of academic credit
that was it there was this point when
you realized this person is in their
element there's these big plumes of you
know frost and cryogenic smoke sort of
billowing through the laboratory and you
know I don't remember exactly what it
was she said but it was something like
isn't this cool
you know she worked on her own research
activities she had a number of graduate
students who worked with her on those
programs she saw that they had not just
the research skills that they needed but
the life skills that they needed
I remember going and parking in the vice
president's spot you know at the
Carnegie Institution and proudly
marching up to her office there was just
a whole level of exposure that you got
if you work for that that you just
couldn't get any other way it's Margaret
who once told me that every student is
an irreplaceable asset in a very real
sense we were sort of an extended family
within a decade the program had grown to
about 3,000 students the undergraduate
research opportunities program is such a
great innovation in higher education and
it's one that we've emulated at Michigan
and of course it has been emulator Dahl
over the country I've had a number of
students tell me that Europe was the
reason they decided to come here by the
middle 80s she was interested in having
a role which gave her a broader sweep
with respect to the undergraduate
educational program she had very deep
thoughts about what a good education
means she made her imprint there by
helping the faculty rethink the role of
the humanities arts and social sciences
at MIT she loved commencements the fact
that MIT has every student recognized
individually was something that was very
she was engaged in those activities and
was looking forward to activities that
would have gone beyond those kinds of
efforts when she was taken ill in the
fall of 1990 I'm extremely proud of the
preparation Margaret gave us she was a
teacher in every respect she was a
teacher of her students she was a
teacher of her colleagues of
institutions in a very important way she
packed a lot of life into 47 years and I
think she would like to have gone on for
about a hundred which I always thought
was about right there's a piece of her
in every one of us and it makes us
stronger more capable people
[Music]
I think for any of us who ever knew
Margaret this is sort of choked up it's
it's uh it's very moving and I really
appreciate everybody who participated in
that in making that film I think it's a
real treasure and especially for the
McVicker fellows you know as time goes
by those of us who knew Margaret
individually are going to be less and
less common around here and I'm really
glad that we have this connection but I
think the point was best said at the end
that there's a piece of her in everybody
who loves to teach and that's what we're
going to turn to now you know at MIT the
demo is part of the culture right and I
don't know though if we've ever had a
teaching demo but we're gonna try that
today and we have a couple I'm going to
introduce a couple spectacular teachers
or we're going to try to do this and
we'll see what happens
that yeah are through you I mean you're
both where's Alex is Alex here Alan says
I mean you guys are among the most
unpredictable people at MIT so I you
know I'm just gonna let it roll okay
Arthur professor of anthropology show us
how you do it in IASP and the next Alex
just come on after Arthur's done I have
to be ruthless this is all about time
pieces and I'm gonna be ruthless about
the time
using your hands and solving problems
[Music]
solve these problems but we're gonna at
least take a slug at him and you're
gonna take a slug at it okay so I do
this in the context of freshmen course
on technologies and cultures
this gentleman spent 40 years solving
this problem he's a English scientist by
the name of John Harrison born in 1693
died in 1776 anybody know what he's
famous for longitude exactly he's the
guy that developed the first accurate
timekeeping instrument that could keep
that could measure the longitude one of
the reasons he was after it after he did
it I suspect is that the prize that the
British government put out in 1714 said
they'd give him 20,000 pounds which was
an enormous amount of money in that
period to a person who could measure the
longitude within
half a degree on a trip from Portsmouth
England to the Caribbean and he set out
to do this it took him 40 years because
no one knew anything about accurate
timekeeping there were other conflicting
methods at the time if a clock could
keep time to within a couple of minutes
a day that was pretty good he began with
this absolutely remarkable gadget that
didn't go all the way to the West Indies
I want to point out to you that it has
wooden gears made of brass and wood has
wooden gears in it it has an
extraordinary temperature compensation
device in there that's made of steel and
brass and because this is on a ship
that's rocking back and forth you can't
use a pendulum clock obviously but he
has opposed pendulums connected together
with Springs very ingenious gadget
pretty accurate but he decided it wasn't
accurate enough so I didn't have a test
it he built two more these are this is
this machine is the size that you're
just looking at there okay he built
another machine suddenly very suddenly
in 70 in the late seventeen fifty 1759
it was finished
it's a watch that's five inches in
diameter why he changed to this size
where he got the idea to change to this
size and no one knows a lot of his
papers are excellent but no one is
really no one has ever really figured
that out this is the heart of that watch
this is the balance wheel with a very
small spring now with all that said you
you're going to have to figure out the
problems that he had to deal with okay
and I'm gonna show you in a minute how
you do it first of all he had the sail
or the clock had to sail the timekeeper
let's say had to sail from Portsmouth
down to the West Indies it was also
supposed to go back obviously but the
prize was supposed to be given for that
one-way trip as a matter of fact he had
a hell of a time winning the prize at
the risk of making a snide observation
he was that he was very geeky kind of
guy this words going to come up again in
Alex's presentation
I realized he probably was a hyper geek
in fact I think you anybody that can
obsess so over over a time keeper for 40
years it's probably almost all he did he
was supported by various and sundry
grants by the way and then build a
machine this is a ch4 is that was silver
thing that I showed you that essentially
lost a minute just under two minutes but
going and coming this was on the first
trip this is unheard of and the board of
longitude which was made up of
professors and Admiralty people and
nobility professors of mathematics
largely incidentally from Cambridge and
Oxford didn't have a clue that a machine
could work like this I mean their pocket
watches didn't work very well okay this
one works a lot better but it's a modern
one okay so if a rate was applied which
means how much against losses every day
in fact only lost five point one seconds
which is absolutely extraordinary given
the you know was traveling on a ship etc
etc so they made him go through a second
trial and again it gained only thirty
nine point two seconds over the one-way
voyage again if her rate was with the
rate applied if you apply temperature
rates as well again it gained only
fifteen seconds which was is really
unheard of was totally unheard of which
is part of the reason why he had so much
trouble getting the prize people simply
thought there was something wrong with
the experiments there wasn't anything
wrong with the experiments these are the
they're amazing pieces of machinery now
here's what we're gonna do I have a lot
of clocks here can someone help me hand
these out
I'd like you to form into groups of
about five okay so talk to people in
front of you talk to people behind you
you're gonna stop II
okay
here let me let me get your attention
for just a second hang on
these are alarm clocks okay these are
very very cheap mechanical alarm clocks
here's what you got to wind them up
slightly okay you lined them with the
left knob the right one is the the other
other right knob sorry and then sort of
shake it so that it starts running okay
here's another one now here's what I'd
like you to do hey my classes are just
as disorderly by the way exactly this
disorderly here's what I'd like you to
do hey you stop good
you're quiet for a second I expected
this would be I'd like you to look at
the clocks pretty carefully I'm not
going to ask you to really figure out
exactly how they work because that takes
too much time okay but I'll tell you
what I would like you to fig to figure
out and I want you to do this you know
jointly as a group what what do you
think are the impediments to making this
thing accurate these are very very
inaccurate clocks they're analogues to
the kind of stuff that Harrison's
contemporaries were using okay I've had
I've had students try to calibrate these
and it's really difficult really really
difficult I mean they're off by as much
as 20 minutes a day in some cases okay
another question how might you correct
these problems now I want you to spend
about five minutes worrying about this
you know talk about it discuss it come
up with some solutions then I think you
probably someone in your group on a
write down on a piece of paper what you
think I'm going to call on someone from
various groups to come up write on the
board what their conclusions are okay
this is the way I run classes that's
what you're getting guys that's what
you're getting here's some paper
yeah
about five minutes yeah that happens
sometimes sorry
have you wound it okay so he's doing the
right thing he's bending it have you
wandered enough to get it Ronnie oh yeah
okay you probably ought to worry about
the inside of it Yeah right
I think it wounds the other way you took
that yeah the winder comes off if you
winded the wrong way you want to get in
a group with these guys
I've given you I've given you a couple
hints you might think about materials
think about the regularity the
oscillator now someone in your group I
hope can figure out what the oscillator
is okay and what its importance is and
then figure out about how you can
regularize the output of the power come
on write something up here hey can I get
your attention back for a minute I got
it really I I obviously have a very
recalcitrant in class oh no here they
come here they come
okay okay someone from over here is
supposed to come help me out but we want
them to write up we want you to write up
your solutions or some solutions right
something yeah go ahead you do it
here here here here oh oh you're gonna
use that piece of board okay good good I
need some more board space for you slip
one in there no it's okay it's okay
leave it leave it leave it
that's good that's a good list that's a
good list
whoa super
that's good that's good that's good
that's excellent
sure has wrong on the left side or one
huh
what's wrong however you wanted however
you want or whatever you want to put
they all want to do it I can't stop them
right
[Laughter]
yeah having fun of course there is the
object I'm gonna start this minute
coming how much I could yeah I will
I'll start okay okay okay
hey can I can I get your attention back
okay good
thanks this is sort of hey class thank
you okay this this is sort of the way I
like the classes to work there's a lot
of commotion there's a lot of discussion
about what's going on people I what I
would do is get the people who are
writing on the board to talk about it
themselves but we don't have time to do
that and then we'd get you know we'd get
we'd start you arguing about no that's
not the way to do it yes that is the way
to do it
you've got really an awful lot of the
stuff which is nice I mean there's there
material problems there bearing problems
whoops we could use that here it is
there's this problem
[Laughter]
there's a there's a quip that any any
MIT faculty member worth his salt can
walk into any classroom and lecture
about what's on the board I'd have a
nice time with this one I have a lot of
acid rain in my pool all right anyway
okay so constant temperature constant
pressure the springs the springs are
just impossibly am very difficult
especially the balance spring that
really crucial one the hair spring on
your on your claw on your clock is it's
a very difficult thing to get beating
the same way in both directions and when
it has a lot of force pushing it every
when it has little force pushing it all
these problems were one that ones that
Harrison dealt with for I said 40 years
solved the problem we obviously don't
have much of a problem anymore of as we
use quartz watches now but the I think
the point still is doing what what I'm
trying to do is engage the students
obviously engage them I was very
intrigued by your very uncomfortable
laugh when I said what I was going to do
but you obviously got into it really
wonderfully you're to be congratulated
for being a wonderful class we you know
we could go on most of the afternoon
talking about these problems I could
show you the way Harrison solve them we
don't have time for that because alex is
going to do something next have you got
any comments about what happened yeah
please smaller there forty students it's
but but you can do it with maybe fifty
but this is much too many people but but
it you know if we'd within within I
think if we had another 15 minutes we're
all probably would have very interesting
discussion going but we don't have the
time to do that
any other comments and queries
experiences reactions no yeah I
yeah which help well you you had a
Mehcad a couple Mechanical Engineers
there which which isn't really fair
there's a clock guy up here which isn't
fair either okay boarding a sailing and
then you I this year I did a bunch of
different experiments to get them to
understand some of these concepts that
are that you've highlighted here we have
experience yeah thanks that's a very
nice comment yeah well in fact the
whining was a problem that watch that
watch was in a box but the trip over was
very very silver waters in a box was
very bumpy and rocky and William
Harrison who was John's son who was in
charge of the experiments John was very
old by this time in the 1760s had to go
and sort of cradle the clock to make
sure it didn't get wet someone had to
take care of it the whining was a huge
problem because four people had to be
present for the whining to make sure
that there wasn't anything and you know
there wasn't any Anthony something wrong
being done yes it is a problem as a
matter of fact an interesting problem
about winding is keeping the power
running to the mechanism while you're
winding it that's something that
Harrison in fact figured out how to do
before anybody else had done before this
is also the guy who developed the
bimetallic strip which powers all your
thermostats okay we owe that we owe the
roller bearing to this gentleman to he's
really quite an extraordinary
character very underappreciated there's
a pile of MIT freshmen that no love a
lot more than they ever wanted to know
about John Harrison the thanks for your
attention
I actually would like the clocks back
eventually okay by the end of the end of
the session I just like everything and
I'm not even gonna try either the Navy
has acid rain in his basement but alex
is that which dear Brit well alex
d'arbeloff and i have co-evolved a major
feature we call it the f-word focus and
everybody knows that in order to do
something really well you have to focus
you have to do things really well so
today we're gonna learn the method of
Frobenius and we'll spend an hour doing
of that and that may sound boring and
we're actually not going to do that it's
a differential equation thingy the you
can do really well and do good if you
focus but as every optics camera person
knows focus is not really the issue to
really excel you have to have what depth
of field which means you can focus over
a very wide range of what you're looking
at that is really the key okay
and what I try to do is get kids besides
break chalk to think about as much stuff
as they can before they spontaneously
combust
because if you think about it in life
there are so many things and if you're
only thinking about just one thing it
gets pretty boring right so that's why
I've got all these doodads out here this
one wins didn't even notice this one
wins and I want to start passing out the
toys and Arthur is the first one does
anybody notice how that flew who wants
one watch how they fly and what I try to
get students to know notice whoa oh oh
sorry Priscilla go to ants camp these
gentlest I try to get people to notice
as much about everything as possible and
this when you keep your eyes open you
get good depth of focus Rohan will take
one does that fly well that way they're
pretty soft Roz is gonna save me okay so
let's start listing things we notice and
your guyses tey have two tasks and I'm
one who believes that the humanity
should be fully integrated with
engineering so we're gonna have two
tasks the first thing is who can develop
the best acronym to summarize everything
we do in the next 15 minutes words who
can develop the best educational toy
using this and who can come up we'll do
this as a team with the most engineering
things about these doodads okay
so what's the first one and I want you
to describe the physics and why and what
happened so we'll start with a little
hint but what I think is the the acronym
to sum up life the universe and
everything okay and I'm attempting to
draw a bulldozer
and there's actually a reason why I
can't draw worth worth anything I'll put
a big pile of dirt here and it's pushing
it along okay so that's your that's a
visual hint okay now let's start with
the engineering thing about how many
engineering principles we can come up
with that are exemplified by these
plungers so what's the first thing that
happened when I came in and when I when
I try to teach I'm not really teaching
what I'm doing is I'm working with my
students because most of my lectures
including this one are totally ad-hoc I
have a general goal of what I want to do
and then I work with my students in
terms of what gets them to have passion
because if you can't have passion
yourself and you can't get your students
to have passion xlvii right so you want
to
it's like snowboarding okay so what's
the first thing what happened when we
came in okay we put it down we put down
two of them and why do we think one let
go before the other excellent and
leakage is caused by so then we'll go
and we'll start analyzing and they
looking at things helped me out so we
had different leakage rates so we had
leakage rates no no no no no drawers
vacuum
they said it I didn't so whenever
students observe a physical effect or
whenever I've observed a physical effect
I start looking at the interfaces and
what happens and according to the clocks
with drives everything is errors
remember these little differential
increments given an epsilon there's a
delta our goal is to find out what
connects the epsilon in the Delta so my
goal is to try to get students to
identify what the overall thing that's
happening is and then what are all the
variables so then we'll just are looking
the interface this is the flatness of
the table there is the the plain arity
of here and then remember that thing
movie the powers of 10 when you move
back so now I look closer and it's not
just the flatness of this is actually a
smoothness here too and there's a mold
line okay and that sort of thing so
we'll have flatness oh by the way what
was the guy Harrison's first name John
John's kind of sounds like George right
so it's kinda like Joe Harrison so I
want people to see if they can detect
this kind of the so John Harrison would
test your history here in history is a
very very important part of engineering
see this is kind of the same especially
since that's why cursive writing was
invented for engineers
this also says Harrison and there's
another Harrison and does anybody want
to put some time on it and why they're
all similar this dude did clocks pardon
this one did laser interferometers he
was dean of science at MIT and then what
30s George Harrison the first Michelson
interferometer Chuck vomiter man
and this dude did music
so if you think about in terms of this
was done dunk dunk the laser
interferometer is the national standard
international standard for distance but
it's really time measure the time of
flight and this guy makes music so maybe
there's something some kind of
connection here it's long enough but but
think of how cellphones work isn't that
amazing that you can have this silly
little thing driving on the highway in
your car with only while you're melting
your brain will only a couple watts and
somehow they pick that signal out
amongst all that loud music that's
playing in my car some geeks figured it
out somewhere how to pull nothing out of
something and make a clear signal and
that's really the essence of what we're
trying to do in engineering whether it's
and I view engineering actually it's not
engineering but creation so we're
creating poems we're creating music
light now what else has happening how
come I haven't seen you guys breaking
these things yet
okay so let's pull on it everybody who's
got one pull on it and tell me what you
start to see huh hoop stress okay so now
we could do an entire mechanics lecture
on this then when you pull here what
happens to the stresses in this thing
okay this thread here I could tell grab
someone to hold it and attempt that yeah
hmm let's see if we can do it over here
we will succeed so we could demonstrate
for example the power of a screw thread
hmm almost maybe let's see if we can get
something else going here would you hold
this can a screw thread does everybody
know what the hell to figure out that
the force from a screw thread we always
would like to resort back to fundamental
principles yeah
and if I'm unscrewing this with very
little effort what's happening who's
winning
you see I'm hardly putting any effort at
all the screw thread is moving what's
happening I'm compressing the bellows so
right away I could make a judgement of
spring force and sooner or later what's
going to happen here
yeah it's ventually it's going to do
this and that right so this is another
thing we try to do is get students to
look at the world around them and very
very fundamental principles and perhaps
the most fundamental principle will be
conservation of energy so again be out
and then there's some for the federal
government
but wow that's a lot this is where all
the missing masses of the universe of
the physicists so let's do our little
test of the power of a screw thread
right
what's screw threads there's a lead and
the lead is for example in millimeters
per revolution okay and I'm gonna apply
some twisting or torque and I want to
know when I twist this thing assuming
this is going into some sort of nut how
much would I apply some torque how much
force is this pushing back with me on
what's happening to this system and what
I try to work with students in design
and often you said well I'm not very
analytical you know III just think
visual I say well no no you can think
any way you want you can think physical
analytical visual whatever method you
want that's really a key is we have to
find many different ways to reach these
students because they all have different
bio neural nets and to say that all
students should do it this way because
this way is the best way all zealots
should be beaten
okay what makes the world so much fun is
all the different stuff I ski you know
and I snowboard on powder and I like I
don't like ice but I like trees and I
like moguls it's the it's the
combination that makes it such a rich
existence of fun
so anyway power in is going to be the
torque and you go through it uh one
revolution times two pi equals well and
I knew I had to go through one
revolution because I got revolution over
here and this is where pattern matching
becomes very important I think I want
people to learn to look at patterns and
grab these weird obscure relationships
because very few things are really just
obvious whim hit you in the face a for
okay so I've got some effort times some
distance equals some effort this is the
force I'm looking for time some distance
effort distance effort distance force
times the lead you can figure out the
force and you can divide by lead and
what you'll find for example assuming
it's really efficient blah blah blah the
force equals the amount of torque you
put in times 2pi divided by the lead
lead may only be a millimeter the torque
may be one newton meter and what sort of
force can we could generate this is
another thing I want people to able to
do is do things in your head real quick
order of magnitude two times pi is about
six okay times one Newton meter
that's Newton times a thousand
millimeters so that's a thousand times
six six thousand divided by one I can
generate 6,000 Newton's of force with
about the torque that I can put on with
my hand it's amazing the power of a
screw
and real slow motion so it's very
important to develop that visualization
okay now so we've got force from a screw
we've got surface finish we've got hoop
stresses there's a lot more engineering
you can do with these things
remember pascal due to invented pressure
trying to remember pascal you feel under
pressure well I teach a course it's
called second summer program at Leo
Osgood an office of minority education
and every January I get about 40
undergraduate freshmen their
undergraduate freshman freshman and we
put him through a two-week boot camp on
how to design and all we do is we just
teach them in one-hour lecture what is
the basic principle of design to find
what you want to do figure out what you
have to do it with and what's the
physics now go define a product you have
two weeks to create the product
prototype the product and make a
professional presentation to a bunch of
industry people and in those two weeks
those kids do about 50 to 70% of what
teams of 10 seniors will do it's
absolutely astounding and they do it
because they don't know they're not
supposed to not be able to do it and
because they have incredible passion
because we give them ownership say
here's how you design here's the field
toys and games now come up with
something and when you empower the kids
this way it is absolutely amazing what
their minds do and even when they make a
guess where they came up for a toy with
this dude clothes bubbles the bubble
blower and discovered you don't need a
ring to blow bubbles actually needs an
orifice and then a when you it bubbles
through and they bubbles up and blows
out the orifice you blow perfect bubbles
every time you don't need one of these
you know and then so they put a seat on
it and they put one as little animal
heads like oh y'all ba ba ba ba and then
you jump up and down it like a pogo
squirting pogo stick in the pool four
little kitties in little pools so we're
gonna run them to file a patent on that
and work with them and teaching on
injection molding yadda yadda yadda so
it's like the book if you give a mouse a
cookie and then you says oh I'm thirsty
he wants to milk some milk there's a
milk mustache has trim the mustache yada
yada yada yada
okay so the goal is you keep going
faster faster faster until they take a
nap but not enough cuz they're hurting
it's because they're having too much fun
now who wants to take a crack at the
acronym test and the best acronym will
win a plunger I don't know everything I
just did or what your vision of what we
want to do with it what we ideally
should try to do with education
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anyway I can't write that I can't spell
hallucinate yeah well just hey okay no
no I'm serious
this goes to be like a moral message
from all this I gave you guys all the
words we even drew you a picture yes
undergraduate design opportunities
program right that cool
see I think woody started it really well
here there's research but there's also
design there could be you mop like
undergraduate music opportunities
program where in any of the religious
texts that I've written does it say it's
got to be an R and I think the spirit of
Markham they picker himself right and I
remember she ran into me a few times
that I was running into the UROP office
cuz I did your op a lot she had I think
more energy than I did that was really
cool
it could be research design music
literature snowboarding scientist
science chemistry
what's research what's design let's let
the kids and that's the thing or my main
message is we admit so many brilliant
brilliant brilliant exciting students I
don't think we met anybody who comes
here harmony in MIT and just and then
get an MIT degree yeah that's not a
statistically significant portion that
we need to empower our students when
they come to us and say listen I don't
fit in a degree program I'm going to
take some computer science so take some
literature some mechanical some music
and I think I put all that together I
can create the future we should listen
to them and I said well no I'm sorry 46
47 in the handbook here so you can't do
that hey so the cool acronym I was
thinking of is this I'll write it and
then you guys see you
come up without the words are you got to
pay the way to the future by nope you
know what let's write all these down
okay so we've got gonna make this the P
board well I think I don't have any more
erasers that so we have remember all
zealots should be beaten so we have
perseverance cursive writing was
invented for engineers oh the other one
personal project play yes now we're
talking
that's how you learn okay pardon
yes okay I was thinking of ways of
learning but all these are great
physical just like we did here with
touching feeling playing what else let's
do the a board now action okay
a we have action
pardon
Apple Apple yes apples have sugar for
more energy
there you go analysis has anybody seen
the pattern this is kind of like you
know ding I'd like to buy a what's that
show I don't have a TV at home so visual
there you go
experience book extraterrestrial I got a
beam up in a minute
education and lighten men whatever the
kids want to make it because in the end
most of these kids and this is something
we have to realize or a lot smarter than
we are
we just have greater follicle impairment
factors okay so thanks lover coming
foods outside
if sandpaper if you needed I was going
to sand the bottom of this and show you
we could actually make it stay almost
all day but we ran out of time thank you
Alex and Arthur that was terrific
i'm kim van de pere I'm proud to be the
second faculty director of Europe as
you've heard a lot today yesterday we
were celebrated the 30th anniversary and
Paul Gray recently wrote these couple of
sentences about Margaret and the
creation of Europe
she was smart wise passionate and
energetic beyond imagining and she by
force of personality and intellect
created what future observers will
regard as the most significant
educational innovation of the last half
of the 20th century I have the pleasure
today of introducing two faculty members
and their students and my view is that
being a successful mentor is one of the
greatest pleasures of being an MIT
professor and today we will hear from
two successful mentors and their
students their professor John a Sigmund
and his student Milly Roy and they will
discuss their work on anti-cancer drugs
and the other is professor Marjorie
Resnick and her students so you Neela
Byrd
so Unni and I've worked together just
recently during ivy we'll discuss the
project Margaret MacVicar amitié oral
histories of MIT women so John
so Millie Roy and I are going to be
playing tag team here could we could you
lower the lower screen thank you very
much I think this is certainly a very
difficult act to follow
after these two really interactive
presentations I think many of you know
I'm a toxicologist and anyway I think
toxicology isn't the kind of thing we
want to interact with in a group setting
anyway although I've got to say I was in
watching Alex I mean I've worked with
aflatoxin some of the most deadly toxins
known to man over my on my entire career
you notice I have a very steady hand but
I think that I almost had a heart attack
when I saw him using the overhead
projector that I have to use with Millie
right now and balancing it on a box of
Kleenex I mean this was juice to me well
anyway
first first of all I think that as as we
all know
Margaret's signature element was Europe
and I think it's terrific to have as a
component of this program a presentation
from UROP students and we're very
delighted to be here now my work can the
work in my lab concerns all cancer
research in particular how cells respond
to DNA damaging agents and it divides
into two parts the first part involves
how chemicals radiation cause cancer in
the other part the part that Millie Roy
and my graduate student Maria Kartal who
work on concerns how chemicals are used
to treat cancer so what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to start out by telling you a
little bit about how cancer is caused
and what the conventional methods are
that we use to treat cancer and then
we're gonna turn things over to Millie
who's gonna tell you about some of her
recent discoveries in Europe and I want
to say that Millie's been a terrific
graduate student she has three
publications to her credit she's the
president of all kinds of undergraduate
op organizations and she's been a
pleasure to have in the lab okay so we
tell you about cancer so I think many of
you know the cancers arise from the
conversion of normal cells into a tumor
cell and the kinds of things that cause
this conversion are
chemicals radiation and to a lesser
extent viruses these cause cancer cells
normal cells to mutate into into cancer
cells that is the acquired genetic
changes and one component my program
were quite interested in that when a
series of genetic changes occurs what
will happen is that the the the cell
will acquire the inability to stop
growing they acquired the commitment
toward unremitting cell division clonal
expansion occurs into this mass on the
right that we call a tumor and there are
two things about tumors I want to
mention first of all the best way to
remove them is by surgery or radiation
and by far the least favorite option for
treating tumors is to treat them with
chemicals and the reason for that is
that when you treat a person with toxic
chemicals the chemicals that we have
available to us today don't show a very
large differential toxicity in favor of
killing the tumor cells over the normal
cells of the body so people suffer a
huge amount of collateral toxicity but
we have to use chemotherapy it's the
best thing that we have and in cases
where surgery and radiation fail so will
happen is in the treatment of a
malignant tumor with chemotherapy is
there'll be a large reduction in tumor
cell mass but it turns out that tumors
grow very quickly and their chromosomes
lose their fidelity and replication in
their chromosomes drops off in fidelity
over time and there are a few cells that
are left that have acquired resistance
new genes have been turned on that make
those cells non-responsive to the
therapeutic modality so what happens is
the patient goes into a brief period of
remission and then the tumor regrows now
the sad thing isn't when the tumor
regrows that it tends to be resistant to
the original types of therapy that we
use to treat it and it's usually the end
for the patient so our interests are and
what are these genes that are turned on
in some cases turned off that make these
tumors either succumb to or resist with
chemotherapy so could I have the next
overhead wheeling now the drug that we
study and most of our work is in the
upper left is called cisplatin this drug
from a clinical perspective is a life
saver for men with testicular cancer
this is one of the very few success
stories where you've got a drug that
actually
chores a disease it's also the drug of
choice for women with ovarian cancer but
in that case it's very much like I've
showed in the previous slide the tumor
initially regresses and then it comes
back and when it comes back it's
typically resistant to therapy we're
interested in why that is what are the
genes that might be turned on now let me
tell you a little bit about cisplatin
from the chemical perspective I worked
together for about 15 years with Steve
Lippert the the chairman and the
chemistry department on this compound
and it enters the cell and undergoes a
set of chemical reactions that result in
it becoming chemically reactive what
that means it will go off and form
chemical bonds with the d8 the basis of
DNA DNA is the cellular target for
cisplatin these little spider like black
objects that you see or what we call
addicts which are the chemical species
cisplatin linked covalently to DNA bases
and these block DNA replication of a
tumor cell they block the ability of
that genome to be expressed as well
so these are the killing lesions now a
number of years ago Steve's lab in my
lab along with Gilbert chose lab at
Stanford discovered that there were
proteins that bound very tightly to some
of these addicts in DNA and we've been
studying these for quite awhile now one
of the things in in a paper that Steve
Lippard recently published shows that
these proteins that bind or at least one
of them has a side chain that inserts
itself if you can see where I'm hitting
the laser right here at the end of the
blue blue arrow between the two bases
that are coordinated by cisplatin and we
think that that insertion of a side
chain might be very much of central
importance in the efficacy of this
specific drug now where this is where
milli takes over and then it turns out
that milli and her mentor Maria Kartal
who realized that there was another
class of proteins called glycolysis that
did this type of insertion of a side
chain into DNA as a critical part of
their mechanism of action now I want to
just say that no one had ever seen any
association between glycosyl ages and
cellular sensitivity to cisplatin before
and I'm gonna tell you 200 things over
to milli now I'll become the audio of
Israel specialist and she'll
so it's John said that Maria and I were
mostly focused with DNA glycosylase --is
which our DNA repair proteins that are
known to repair oxidized bases and they
weren't previously known to be
implicated in the repair of cisplatin
DNA damage I guess something that
happened was there was a discovery that
these glycolysis actually had a common
feature with those platinum binding
proteins that John had mentioned earlier
that insert that amino acid signed
sidechain and and that's exactly what we
saw on the right there
the blue and the red structure on the
right is a glycosylase and you see that
it's inserting a non-polar residue into
the DNA helix and that's how it's
actually getting in there and doing the
repair and so this kind of gave us a
clue into the action of these like ah
slices and made us want to probe into
whether these glycolysis act in the
repair of cisplatin DNA adducts and so
from this arose two main questions and
one is whether the glycolysis bind to
this is plantain addicts and Maria
experimented through biochemical means
and she found that three of the
glycolysis is actually bind to the a
ducts and then the second question that
arises from that is is this binding
biologically important and this is what
I studied and I approached this on from
a genetic standpoint and when you do
that what you do is you actually study
bacterial bacterial strains and actually
just kind of get rid of the glycosylase
and study the effects and so that's
exactly what I did the experiments that
I did Maria and I worked on two
glycolysis in particular we worked on
mute and mute Y which are both DNA
repair proteins involved in the base
excision repair pathway which is just
one DNA repair pathway and what we did
is we use e coli cells which is very
popular strain of bacteria and we
knocked out that the different proteins
but with mute Y and mute mute AB and so
in the first set you see on the left
over there we knocked out the mute Y
protein and we administered cisplatin
frank doses and we study the survival
rates as compared to the wild type
strain which has all of its proteins
intact so in the mute in the cells that
lack mute y-you see that there's
significantly there's a significant drop
in survival as compared to the wild
types and so from that you can kind of
extrapolate that mute why in some way
protects the e.coli cells from cisplatin
toxicity similarly with the mute will M
case we got bacterial strains that
lacked the mute M protein and we did the
same experiment we administered
cisplatin in different doses and we
studied the survival rates and in this
case you actually see higher survival
rates as compared to the wild type and
this may seem paradoxical because both
mute and mute wire are DNA repair
proteins that are involved in the same
pathway but they show very different
results and so these results basically
point to the fact that these glycolysis
dusa do probably play some sort of a
role in defining the cellular
sensitivity to spottin so after you get
data and you get results i think the
next step is to come up with some sort
of a model to frame the problem and to
really allow future experiments to be
performed so the model that maria and i
came up with to explain our results
first with the mute y case because we're
saying that me Y is somehow protecting
the cells from cisplatin toxicity we're
thinking that mute why it's normal
substrate and is an august oxidized base
we're saying it could also possibly go
in and repair this as plantain addicts
that we see we haven't actually seen
this yet in the lab but that is a
possibility or it could actually be
recruiting a DNA repair complex to get
the addict repaired and then the addict
ends up getting repaired and that leads
to cell survival in the mutant case
which is very different we're thinking
mute M in some ways sensitizes the cells
to cisplatin and how does that happen
we're thinking that mute m may bind to
the addict and prevent the action of the
DNA repair complex it in some way
obstructs the vision from the DNA repair
complex and then that ik cysts and that
leads to cell death so this model
basically points to the fact that mute Y
is protecting the cells from cisplatin
by recruiting another repair complex and
mute M is potentiating cisplatin
toxicity by inhibiting the repair of
cisplatin addicts and so these are
basically our working hypothesis and it
really presents opportunities for drug
design and if you've seen the red down
there if we if you actually take a look
at the next step would be to take a look
at resistant tumor cells and see if
there is in fact an upregulation of
human meat Y in those cells that would
lead to tumor resistance or a down
regulation of human um that would lead
to the tumor resistance and then once
we've actually seen that and can
establish that hopefully to come up with
certain drug possibilities perhaps for
example an inhibitor to mute Y that
might lead to tumor sensitivity and to
possibly overcome the problem of tumor
resistance to cisplatin so and these are
the kinds of approaches that are left to
be performed and on the basis of these
conclusions and right now I just um I
wanted to talk a little bit about my
Europe experiences I'm a senior right
now and and just how they've shaped my
academic career at MIT I've been
involved in the Europe program since my
freshman year and I really had the
opportunity to gain a tremendous amount
of insight from the vastness of
biological research as a biology major
with hopes of becoming a doctor I feel
that MIT is Europe opportunities have
really provided me with an essential
research background and have enhanced my
understanding of several concepts in
both biology and chemistry as I prepare
to leave MIT after this semester I know
that the experiences and knowledge that
will have been the most significant to
me will be those from my Europe
experiences and that's because the
ability to experience something hands-on
provides a unique and satisfying means
of learning about a subject matter the
book learning was of course essential to
my basic understanding of scientific
principles but it's putting the book
learning to actually use and practice
that really allows an imp
to be made I chose MIT as my
undergraduate school because of the
research opportunities I would gain as
compared to those at other schools and
I'm thrilled to be able to leave here
feeling that I was more than correct in
that decision specifically the project
that I worked on in John's lab may
directly affect my interactions with
patients as I go on to pursue a career
in medicine in a clinical setting I'm
almost certainly will encounter many
cancer patients because cancer is in
fact the second leading cause of death
in this country many of these patients
will be treated with chemotherapy and
unfortunately as some of these people
will become resistant to their drug
therapy my Europe gives me a clearer
idea of the biological basis of
resistant and it also gives me a well
informed way in which to explain to my
patients the reality of their disease
finally I'm hopeful that the science
that I've done as a Europe will point to
new ways that future urops can explore
to overcome the human problems of
resistance to cancer drug therapy thank
you very much
[Applause]
well you might think that I feel totally
marginalized as a humanist and the last
person and a person who's going to speak
about women and women's history but I
don't because actually Milly Roy was in
my class and she was also a Burchard
scholar which is the program I run so I
feel a connection let me begin by saying
that the Margaret MacVicar women's oral
history project documents the life
histories of women graduates from MIT as
they're collected and recorded and
transcribed many people gain access to
these materials which really have three
purposes first they give us a sense of
what who would the path breakers who are
the women who in the early 20s and the
30s were engaging in careers in science
and technology when very few other women
were secondly they give us a sense of
what these women's lives were like what
were their barriers how can we better
address those problems they faced in the
past today but finally and possibly most
importantly they give us a sense of MIT
as an institution because although we
have many wonderful histories written
about us as an institution about our
faculty and about our administration
very many of those unfortunately have
grade lacunae when it comes to the
contributions of women now this resource
the fact that it is an oral history is
very very important because first of all
it's done by undergraduate students and
they work with me and in developing the
kinds of questions they're going to ask
our women graduates they have a chance
to think about their own lives their own
concerns and what they can possibly
learn from older women it also gives
them a chance to understand firsthand
what I always lecture about and that you
probably know that Mary Wollstonecraft
and what she said in thoughts on the
education of women to have in this
uncertain world some stay which cannot
be undermined is of the utmost
consequence and students learn firsthand
what did that mean to these women the
funding for this project comes entirely
from amitié the association of MIT women
graduates we have an endowment over a
thousand dollar endowment that feeds
this program and we named it when
Margaret died Margaret had helped me
very very much as an individual as we
thought out how is this project because
you can imagine there are all kinds of
fights whom should we interview who are
the most important women should it be
famous women should it be the women who
very stop fiddling with your clock if he
was in my class I'd make him talk about
the clock at the interrupted me to say
okay but anyhow when we started the
project you can imagine there were lots
of arguments should we only interview
women who were famous in their field how
should we determine who was going to be
first and Margaret and I debated over a
year at the inception of this project as
to how we can decide how to begin and I
said finally let's begin with the oldest
so I'm going to show you because we did
complete all the women in the class of
1922 before they died I'm going to tell
you a little bit about they're all
histories and then we're going to see a
video a very three-minute video of a
student who completed four of them and
then talk to cerini who's a freshman and
who's just started working on the
projects let me show you these three
we decided to do oral history because
oral history doesn't tell us you know
when people write about their lives they
tend to be very linear and they say well
I went to high school I got this award I
got that one oral histories tend to show
life's processes people tend to talk
about the private dimension the personal
and institutional relationships they
have and there's a wealth of information
that really gets written in biography
oral history probes for recollections of
roles and relationships and particularly
vents and settings as well as seeking
information about an individual's
perceptions and responses to people and
issues we can also learn how these
graduates practice that field how why
for whom and for what rewards they work
and how they feel about it there are
also wonderful for networks I remember
that in the course of reading I the
student goes and does the interview and
then I help with the editing reading one
from a graduate in the 50s she said and
I remember this woman
Vilma s beam and you know I think she's
married to Raul Castro no but I will
customize Fidel's that's my other field
Spanish but I will Castro is Fidel's
brother
so I one of my colleagues was going to
Cuban I said Elizabeth please apparently
there's an MIT student from the 50s who
married but I will Castro take her this
letter so I wrote this very nice letter
saying I'm the head of this MIT oral
history project and if indeed you
remember anything about the 50s would
you agree to an interview which might
have to be done by I thought about
distance learning because I've been
working in that and she brought back
just about three weeks ago yes
so hopefully Raul Castro's wife who was
here in 1952 will be part of the oral
history project but what it gives for
our students is a sense of I am back and
let me just share with you some words
that come out of these interviews at the
end of one interview the alumnus says
quote I was just thinking it would be
interesting to interview you and the
student says oh I've only been around a
couple of years I don't have all that
much to say and the Alumni the alumnus
says forty years from today when you're
sitting someplace you'll see it's fun to
remember all this stuff the student says
oh yeah reminiscing that's
the alum says I usually don't think
about it but obviously a lot of stuffed
away there I feel sorry for whomever
translates this the student says it's me
and the alum says well skip anything you
want and the student says never
everything you've said is so awesome in
another interview a student who lives in
McCormick Hall surrounded by the formal
pictures that those of you have been in
McCormick know mrs. McCormick here's
this alum say mrs. McCormick invited us
to tea I didn't know what to expect and
she said well young ladies thank you for
coming here glad to see you all I assume
you all know about birth control and the
students said I can't believe it you
mean mrs. McCormick and Norma who is
house manager McCormick but I was house
master we'd sit there we'd look at these
posters who could believe that this
woman dressed so formally could say that
and neither could our students but among
the completed oral histories are these
are all histories of these three women
who graduated from MIT in 1922 Martha
Munster she's the one closest to me
Marjorie Pierce and Bertha dodge in the
very few minutes we have today I want to
introduce you to them in their own words
so that you can imagine what it was like
for our 19 year old students to come
face-to-face with the past and with
these women for whom risk was just not
important at all Martha Munster who was
born in 1899 majored in electrical
engineering the student says how did you
get into science thinking that she's
going to be this great pioneer and a
woman who thought long and hard and
Martha said I often wonder what it is
that makes you choose a certain path of
path of life and sometimes it's because
your family were all doctors or lawyers
and you decided to follow in their
footsteps or perhaps you had an
inclination for a special field well in
my case and please don't laugh it was
because they had a crush on my science
teacher augustus clark and if he had
taught Latin I might have become an
ancient language major but he was a
physics and chemistry teacher and felt
that I should become a scientist so I
did I was supposed to go to Smith but a
friend said you should go to MIT I went
to see the D
he said you're not for us I said if I
pass the exams will you take me I
suppose we'll have to and that's how I
got here
Martha is she published widely she
became a real activist for environmental
issues well into her 90s incidentally
one of the positive aspects of this
project is that I get to have ongoing
communication with the alums even when
the interviews are done and she called
me all the time but Eleni died Janice
who was the student who interviewed
Martha wrote in an essay from my class a
different class that I wanted to share
with you
Martha Munsters spunk has served her
well over a lifetime she survived a life
so wrought with trial and tribulation
that many would have given up long ago
a mother's depression and near suicide
an unhappy marriage a lover illegal
abortion and her own daughter's mental
illness she outlived two husbands and
her son Martha's curiosity about life
always led her to new adventures and new
careers she's a scientist teacher writer
environmentalist mother and swimmer
knowing her has changed my concerns
about choosing the right major /
determining my future the way so many of
my peers try to do it's given me the
strength to know you can pace great
sadness and still look back on a life
well-lived in a sense that one can go
forth from MIT and reach the goals to
which one aspires Marjorie Pierce died
recently and in rereading the transcript
of her oral history she was an architect
we hear that risk-taking determination
again quote if I had stayed at
Charleston Maine I could have stayed
there the rest of my life but in that
office I never would have gotten
anyplace as a woman nor as an architect
so I cut the umbilical cord and started
out on my own and the student voice
which on the tape I have these on tape
says sort of quivering but weren't you
scared of leaving a firm and going out
on your own and Marjorie said of course
but you have to turn discrimination to
advantage when clients said well I don't
think a woman is as practical as a man I
turned it around and said look men don't
know how a house works they don't know
how a kitchen works why should they
design it here's a stove that men
designed and you have to reach across
the burners to turn it off I've done
more than a thousand
houses and I'm 90 and still taking jobs
there's a new house to do in Lexington
and I'm thrilled
and finally Bertha dodge who graduated
from Radcliffe College and then came to
MIT tells the student MIT is much nicer
to deal with than Radcliffe and a
student said well weren't you worried
about the students are always if it
weren't you worried weren't you worried
about being only one of six women at MIT
no I don't frighten easily and now I
should say Bertha dodge published very
widely in plant biology and when we
collect the artifacts of these women for
the permanent archive at MIT we have
their books we have letters we have
anything the family gives them but I had
made the mistake of saying to the
student who was I think only a freshman
when she did the interview
Anusha listen you know she was Norbert
Wiener sister so the student not on my
advice said well what was it like to be
Norbert Wiener sister she gets furious
you have to listen to them but she said
I thought this interview was about me
not about him why is everybody asking me
about my brother and the student tries
to get out of it very interesting and
then dodge explained how she taught
chemistry for several years at
Washington University and she said that
wasn't what I was intending to do as a
career I wasn't intending to be a writer
either it just happens and the students
as well what were you intending to do
and she said well I'll answer as they
say in Spanish quien sabe who knows a
lot of things happen in life that way
you don't plan for it but if you're
qualified and the opportunity comes you
take it I wanted to save the time to
heat for you to hear from two students
who have participated in the project
right now you're gonna look at my
virtual student because she's now in
medical school rail and Hartke who did
four interviews and I cut these three
minutes tape from an IEP offering that I
did with Jill ker Conway and Charlie
whiner who's now emeritus from STS on
the project and I thought you'd like to
see what Relan says about the project
and then meet cerini who's just on her
first interview so can you show the
video of Ellen
to give us an example of some of that
work well I'll tell you first of all
that this was the most moving thing I've
done while at MIT and it stayed with me
longer than most of the other work I've
done here it was done it was very
important scholarly I mean to place
things of a woman's life and historical
and social context but I'll be very
honest I mean this was very intimate and
a very personal story and that affected
me I mean it still does I think about it
I said think about it for hours
so although though it was an academic
endeavor it was personal it became very
personal and I think Marjory really
touched on that that's it's what
happened I'll just briefly give you a
sketch of the woman I spoke with over
the course of two interviews in several
hours the woman is about 70 years old
when I spoke with her she went to MIT in
the late 30s graduated in three years
did very well went to medical school
during World War two
also finished medical school in three
years she was very did a lot of research
clinical research very very pioneering
type work I'm a lot of publications and
open heart surgery and a pacemaker she
was very very much a part of that and
did a lot of research I'll tell you in
her life very much was was reflected of
the general ideas that you would expect
and many of the things that dr. Conway
referred to what I found very
interesting in that she did mention her
family her husband and three children
Olli and Pasi and Olli the prompted she
was very consumed with her career and
her research all along and that is very
much what what she was concerned with
relating she also talked very frankly
about discrimination and relayed
absolutely just these horrid incidents
of harassment
especially during medical school
she also talked about the problems of
you know trying to deal with her family
and work when she did talk about it she
talked about how difficult it was and so
those things were all there there were
many more personal aspects and I think
what affected me from this interview is
that so much of what she said about her
experiences I see reflected in my women
peers today at MIT and and as someone
just graduating from MIT that's really
what I could relate to at this point and
that's really what I saw when she spoke
for example she's done all these
incredible things and I was literally in
awe of this woman and more than once she
would talk about how things she had
accomplished were really a joke she
referred to things as a joke I mean she
really you know she said I was just I
was working as hard as I could and just
getting by she did this incredible lack
of self-confidence you know from this
amazing woman and it struck me so much
because I see that in many of my peers
at MIT today the women were say well if
I can do this well it just means that
anybody could do it or I couldn't
possibly you know major in that or I
couldn't possibly do this or what I've
accomplished well it can't be that
important and I'm not saying that I see
that in every woman in my classes but
it's very prevalent and I it struck me
much of what she talked about was
different you know being 50 years ago
and yet there were so many things direct
quotes that I hear women and in my teeth
say today about things they're bitter
about or things that they've I found
gave them strength very similar so Unni
and so you Neely Byrd has just finished
she's a freshman and she's just finished
her first oral history and I hope she
does more I was interested in the oral
history project firstly because I wanted
to look at pioneers and people who are
making a difference
okay so I guess I was a bit different at
first because I decided to do a young
person and everyone was doing the older
people because I wanted to see somebody
who was doing it now
sorry interviewed dr. Patricia Christy
and she's working at ESG now and I was
just so impressed by how dedicated she
was to education everyone's doing their
research they give a lecture they go
back into the research and she was here
really concerned with the students and
it really impressed me how
unintimidating she was you know okay I'm
a woman and I'm gonna do all of this and
she has so much planned I really enjoy
working at the Europe project so thanks
to everyone who set it up because I
found a mentor in Marjorie Resnick and I
found a mentor in dr. patricia christie
who is now one of my close friends and I
couldn't have done it without the UI
project plus I now have a role model so
that's just briefly what I did and what
I thought of it so thanks
[Applause]
I'd like to say one one thing at the end
and why I do this project it's labor
intensive that there are lots of
theories about women around all kinds of
theories about women and I feel that
anyone who sits and reads the archives
and looks at the lives of MIT women will
see them as a cautionary tale against
the myriad theories that try to
determine how women should be how women
learn how we should get married or not
how we should have children not how we
should dress and what I love about these
theories but what I love about the oral
histories is that they define women's
growth and prove that the American Dream
transcends gender thank you
well I I think the last hour or so it's
just been spectacular and I really want
to thank all the people who have
participated and I'd also like to thank
Meraz wood for organizing this day and
I'd like the round of applause for
everybody and it was just about an hour
ago it was about two minutes into
Arthur's presentation that I began to
realize it was much better to let it go
on a little longer and cut short at the
end here I'm supposed to lead a
pedagogical discussion and just saying
it I can't even okay so instead of the
meta discourse I think it was better to
have the discourse and it's also better
to have the discussion among ourselves
outside with the tapas so I just invite
you to join me out there now and again
thank you for coming and participating
you